auf dem skihang sieht es schon nach
totaler harmonie aus 30 wintersportler
aus südkorea waren eine einladung nach
nordkorea gefolgt um gemeinsam zu
trainieren
zwei tage lang wedelten die sportler aus
den beiden ländern zusammen den hang
herunter
diese skifahrerin war von dem ausflug in
den norden begeistert ich bin überrascht
dass die nordkoreanischen sportler so
gute trainingsbedingungen haben sie
haben wirklich sehr gut trainiert und
waren sehr freundlich zu uns das hat
wirklich spaß gemacht und war wichtig
für uns vom 9
bis 25 februar finden im südkoreanischen
pyeongchang um die olympischen
winterspiele statt
beide koreanischen staaten hatten eine
teilnahme nordkoreas an den spielen
vereinbar
so wird es ein gemeinsames eishockey
damen team geben
nordkoreanische sportler werden außerdem
im eiskunstlauf eisschnelllauf sowie im
skilanglauf und im alpinski antreten
bei der eröffnungszeremonie werden die
athleten beider staaten hinter der
sogenannten fahne der vereinigung laufen